major Marvel phase four details of the
MCU have been leaked and it is super
exciting how's it going everybody it's
Warren and we have some leaks on
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 Doctor
Strange - in a new villain trilogy that
is coming to phase 4 I'll talk about all
the leaks in this video but first be
sure to subscribe to my channel I
started a new giveaway and at 400,000
subscribers I'll be picking not one but
three winners and each will get to
choose one item that they want from the
Marvel Legends series collection and
I'll talk more about the giveaway at the
end of this video so like I said we have
some major Marvel phase for leaks and
this comes from somebody who leaked some
things about Avengers in game that ended
up being 100% correct these come from
Twitter user Rodger Wardell back in 2018
Rodger tweeted out many scenes that
ended up being in Avengers endgame and
now he's back at it given us leaks about
Marvel's face for today he tweeted about
what to expect in guardians of the
galaxy volume 3 and Doctor Strange - his
tweets read Rockets creator is the High
Evolutionary Drax's in for a big
surprise when he discovers his daughter
is alive rocket also gets a love
interest in the form of lilah nebula and
star-lord will grow into closer friends
it makes perfect sense that Rockets
creator would be the High Evolutionary
someone who is known for experimenting
on animals turning them into a higher
life form and in the comics the High
Evolutionary does fight with Thor and
Thor's now part of the as guardians of
the galaxy with rocket and it's
interesting that they would bring in
lady Lila to be a romantic interest for
rocket in the comics lady Lila is an
otter and she is rocket soulmate so it
looks like we're going to be seeing a
cat raccoon fall in love and guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 it obviously makes
sense that nebula and star-lord would
become closer friends because they're
most likely going to be searching for
Gamora together in guardians vol 3 and
it will definitely be interesting to see
how Drax is daughter is actually still
alive and Roger also tweeted about
Doctor Strange - in the tweet reads
Doctor Strange to 1980s Boogaloo Tilda
Swinton is in talks to return as the
ancient one Jericho drum and Clea will
make their MC 8 abused Clea will likely
be portrayed by an Asian actress most
importantly the gloves will be back the
introduction of Jericho
drum has actually already been laid in
the first Doctor Strange film Jericho's
brother Daniel drum was actually the
keeper of the New York sanctum and
Doctor Strange before he was murdered by
K Silius and it makes sense to introduce
Clea as well because both Clea and drum
have been central characters to the
Doctor Strange comics and it's no
surprise that the ancient one would be
back in dr. strange too we did see her
in Avengers and game even after her
death so no big surprise there and last
year Roger actually tweeted about the
Thunderbolts being a trilogy coming to
the MCU he tweeted don't worry Marvel
still has big plans for Zemo ghosts
Justin Hammer general Ross and the
abomination the leader is being
discussed to return as the main villain
of Thunderbolts which is being planned
as a trilogy this is actually very
interesting because one of the main
complaints from Marvel fans is that the
MCU sort of just kills off it's really
good villains and I think a lot of
people were very disappointed with
Captain America Civil War where Zemo
kind of just got captured at the end and
the comics Zemo actually forms the
Thunderbolts with the intentions of
getting back at Captain America they
were originally known as the Masters of
evil but disguised themselves as
superheroes they actually do really good
work as superheroes and most of them
stay superheroes but of course Baron
Zemo turns on them and they all go
against him so the Thunderbolts could be
an awesome trilogy coming to the MCU so
let me know what you think about these
face for leaks for the MCU like I said
Roger Wardell leaked many things about
Avengers in game that were 100% accurate
and correct so let me know what you
think about these and don't forget about
my giveaway I'm going to be picking
three winners at the 400,000 subscriber
mark each winner will choose one item
that they want from the Marvel Legends
series collection there will be multiple
ways to enter for multiple chances to
win that I will introduce in the next
few days but of course you have to be
subscribed to my channel to enter the
giveaway and of course be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Marvel as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby
now you're number